Oh my God everybody we got a full-blown gypsy
versus Vibe battle in the episode so let's
break it down she's going to be crazy, but
because the schedule is a little different
this week I have some announcements at the
end of the video, and I will add links in
the description for everything new round of
the flash ring giveaway starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss any of my episode videos the big
thing here is this is the gypsy versus Vibe
episode so it's very Cisco centric, but number
five is a very special reason why they picked
her character specifically for this episode
she debuted in Justice league of America annual
number 2 during 1984, but she was also a huge
character during Vibe's comic book run during
the new 52.
Which you know big coincidence was written
by the show runner of the flash Andrew Kreisberg,
so she has really special significance to
the Cisco character in the comics but also
to the people who write the flash so just
really cool Easter egg right there during
that story line she was in interdimensional
traveler a gypsy if you will see what they
did there fleeing from Cisco's brother rupture
who is being controlled by this big evil person
who I'll explain in a second so Cisco steps
into help her they go on the run together
then they form a special bond.
So you can see that's kind of playing out
over the course of the trailer she's kind
of an antagonist, but they're very playful
about it.
Cisco wants to take her on a date.
So number four what you learn in the comics
is that her father is this evil metahuman
warlord called Mordeth who was exposed to
the raw energies of a boom tube from Apokolips
giving him a much more powerful version of
what Cisco's powers are, so gypsy's real name
is Cynthia Mordeth the actor who is playing
her is Jessica Camacho some of you might recognize
her from Sleepy Hollow, but even though in
the comics her father's this crazy warlord
that has powers given to him by something
from Apokolips.
I don't know if the gonna do him on the TV
show so she might just be a regular metahuman
number 3 from earth 19.
That's why she's coming for HR they explained
the premise of the episode is that interdimensional
travel is outlawed on earth 19 HR broke that
law when he came to Earth 1.
So she's trying to track him down to take
them back to prison, so full-blown gypsy versus
Vibe battle but she's way more bad ass and
way better with her powers than Cisco is.
So it seems like Barry tries to stop her and
she just shuts him down instantly.
So Cisco has to step in in the comics her
powers are little bit different but she does
have some vibe type powers she has Illusion
casting camouflage she can make people see
crazy things to freak them out she has a form
of precognition which is kind of like Cisco's
Vibe ability he can vibe into the future she's
an expert in combat.
So even without her powers she is a total
bad ass, so you get the sense here that even
though Cisco's training with the gauntlets
which it looks really awesome and number 2
Cisco gets the full vibe costume.
He's going to have to find some other way
to defeat her even though he's getting better
with his powers she's just so good and the
way she seems like she's a pretty good person
she is not evil she'll start working with
them, they will find some other way to resolve
the conflict the really cool thing you may
notice in the background or the King shark
and tar pit cutouts that he's using for target
practice.
Now we've been talking a lot about gorilla
Grodd, but King shark will eventually come
back to remember it's the multi-verse.
So all these big flash characters will reappear
at some point don't don't ever be surprised
when big characters come back anybody that's
a fan favorite like the reverse flash or even
Eddie will always come back in some way is
just a matter of finding the right story finding
out when they can fit that in when they can
fit it in their budget because sometimes they'll
blow their wad on big CG episodes like this
two-part gorilla city episode that's coming.
So don't worry King shark will come back soon,
but number 1 because gypsy was a member of
the Justice league in the 80s shall probably
end up working with team flash.
Eventually, but because she's from earth 19
she probably won't stay forever, but she might
come back for brief runs like Jesse quick
or Jay Garrick characters that are from other
Earth's but the come help team flash up for
a couple episodes and they go back to wherever
they came from what it seems like what they're
implying is is that Cisco, who is going to
be obsessed with her in the way he was obsessed
with golden glider, but who knows in the future
season.
They might make her a bigger character in
speaking of the future, the thing about the
vibe costume is that we actually saw it when
Cisco Vibed Caitlin when she was worried about
killer Frost stuff, so we saw the full on
killer Frost versus Vibe in costume fight
that might be from the future when they don't
change that thing from the headlines they
had on the board.
Now, with all the things that they're trying
to change things like the gorilla textile
probably going to happen.
So use have to imagine that Cisco was Vibing
a future from before they started changing
things, so it still darkest timeline when
he's seeing this fight.
You also noticed that Doctor alchemy is working
with the team.
They let him on in the last episode, so now
were gonna find out what he's doing with them,
but the way Caitlin tells it, he's a metahuman
expert.
So he's going to help them deal with all the
other new people that pop up, but I know everybody's
wondering if you gonna betray the team if
he has something to do with savitar escaping
the speed force again.
Even though the philosopher's stone was thrown
into the speed force there are number of things
that could change for each of the characters
they explained that the flash prophecy will
sort of rotate depending on the events that
they change.
So the person that betrays the team might
have been different in the original timeline
before they started changing things.
So someone will die.
Someone will suffer a fate worse than death.
Someone will betray the team, no matter what
happens and the people that those things happen
to will change.
So I'll do a video about the flash prophecy
in a couple days because it's a pretty big
deal.
Let me know what you guys are most hyped about,
and I'll say congratulations to the new flash
ring giveaway winner Andy please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner when I
post my legends video in a couple more hours
so that will post before my arrow video so
it will be legends then my Arrow episode while
you guys wait for that to post click here
for last night's flash episode and you can
click here to learn about the flash is greatest
power in season 3.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you guys tonight!